Hausa Gomez - fear welcome to talking
2.0 is not a thing god damn it try to
zoom to five Friday my brother Pat has
always been about the love for my bros
my fans I thought for at least one time
only that we would check out the
opposite of all that the most horrible
and darkest place on earth
no not your mom's bike I'm talking about
the YouTube spam comments let's do it
it's getting a little bit annoying how
instead of having periods or pewdiepie
he now calls himself
pudy pie or Poots it's getting so
annoying I'm not being mean like but can
he please change his name back to
periods well to be honest my I'm sorry
don't hurt me why is that so annoying
anyway I don't understand my videos are
better you are probably right
just check your channel there are no
uploads what it's right he doesn't have
any videos the quality sucks - and your
vid made me bored in less than thirty
ten seconds but wait I thought he didn't
have any videos oh my god that is so
cool Wow
kill yourself
if you do it first I promise I will do
it too I'm sorry don't kill him because
you will probably sue me even though
you're dead but okay let's just move on
my dad calls me a [ __ ] whoa
thanks for sharing shut the [ __ ] up you
[ __ ] [ __ ] wait a minute
that [ __ ] right is the thumbnails always
old people that's because they're
obviously my my target audience Oh a
Jesus Freak he needs help
yep goodbye sucks and he is not funny
[ __ ] the bro army I'm the best I'm
saying this to get attention well at
least you're honest
thank you sir appreciate it dear friends
I have something to tell you
Peter pie stole my subscribers and you
can see how on my new video on my
channel this is very important because
he may steal your subscribers - this is
with a new hack he made I have something
to confess this might be a little hard
to understand but he's not lying I stole
those subscribers all 0 of them I am so
sorry I [ __ ] hate you P de pie you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] with gay fight hair
you can make fun of me you can make fun
of my hair but if you make fun of my
hair I'll [ __ ] stab a [ __ ] look he's
crying don't listen to them ya know
they're only jealous PewDiePie is stupid
he's talentless and steals other
people's viewers watch yogscast for some
real fun instead of these douche hogs
cast
I got a John M here can you please take
him I don't want him it's me free pie
you suck and you swallow
he's not even funny alright you know
what that's fine that's that's totally
fine everyone is entitled to their own
opinion even though you're [ __ ] wrong
rehashing joke since 2012 what the [ __ ]
did you [ __ ] say about Cod you little
[ __ ]
I was playing call of duty before it was
mainstream man that's [ __ ] hardcore I
think we just found call of duty hipster
they're very rare these days I'm so
proud I hate you you [ __ ] swearing
[ __ ]
woody pies so do they write this with
our face or some [ __ ] like that you
[ __ ] [ __ ] suck my dick you [ __ ] gay
as [ __ ] suck my dick
I really don't yet all these comments
being hateful towards gay and then
wanting you to suck their dick like
that's gay that's really really [ __ ]
gay but that's okay I don't judge hey
how can three if I have 26 million
subscribers while there's only 70 to 80
million people on earth fake a [ __ ] I I
don't know how to explain that to you
you might just die from a brain fart
alright Bryce that's about it for these
comments like I said I really hope I
don't send mixed messages here I have
been telling you bros to not reply to
these comments and I think your brothers
have really listened and I really really
appreciate that that actually means a
lot to me
it's know that I don't care and neither
should use I appreciate that kiddo so
thank you brother but I think what's
even more important is that the fact
that these type of comments are
literally a tiny tiny fraction for
compared to all the support that I get
from you bros and that's really the
reason why I make videos because I get
so much back from you the viewers who's
watching that that's that's the fun for
me that's why I love what I do and
that's why I love making videos ever
since the beginning it's been so much
fun and I still love it just because of
you
that being said thank you boys for
watching I'll see you in the next video
bros this one's for you stay awesome